suzan the soviets thanks for that report
we'll be talking to you obviously
throughout the course of this newscast I
want to bring somebody in now that I'm
really excited about having on this show
he's totally different from most of the
people that we talked to he's gained his
fame on YouTube of all places where
people go to see how he explains things
that many of us frankly don't understand
so let's start with the basics Sal Kahn
thanks so much for being with us from
the Kahn Academy by the way a basic
question explain to our viewers explain
to the million people out there what is
actually broken that we need to fix
right and and and right now we have so
many the stock market goes down every
day and people are having foreclosures
and and you know banks are stopping
lending and they're failing so it's
really hard for people to keep track of
what is the problem is are these just
causes of the problem or the actual
problem so we I think we need to take a
step back and I've drawn a little
diagram here let's put it up draw a
little diagram here and I think there's
a basic fundamental question that we all
have to ask and and what does the
financial system do they make a lot of
money
hopefully they add some value to our
economy and this diagram essentially
explains what the financial system does
so in a capitalist economy you have a
lot of people with capital that could be
land that could be gold that could be I
don't know animals that could be cash
and what you need to do in order to make
the economy grow is invest that capital
into projects build factories of plow
seeds
hire people and what the financial
system does the banks and the markets
they take that capital and hopefully
they allocate it on on projects that
actually put people to work
hire people grow our GDP the problem
right now is is as opposed to the
financial system actually putting more
capital into the real world it's for the
most part more concerned with
self-preservation at the moment they're
kind of in survival mode and because
they're in survival mode you don't have
this flow of capital going from whoever
has it to the financial system and then
to the projects you pretty much have
everything just going back into the
financials
because it's in essentially finite
survival mode so I see the financial
system in the middle that why is that
piece broken explore all out one up for
us sure and and here I'm going to I'm
going to attempt to give everyone a five
minute MBA but essentially what I've
done here is our balance sheets for some
banks and and it might sound like a
complicated term but a balance sheet is
I think something that that most people
are fairly familiar with when they talk
about home equity so if I were to draw a
balance sheet for someone's house it
would look something like this
so the asset and would be your house
whatever it's worth and then your
liability and I'll call that a for asset
and then your liability would be your
mortgage your liability would be the
loan mm-hmm now if your house is worth a
million dollars and you're alone let's
say you owe 800,000 on your loan mm-hmm
whatever's left over is your equity
right that's a balance sheet that's a
balance sheet that I think most people
are fairly familiar with for
corporations they have the exact same
notion and I think this is an important
point to realize when people talk about
the stock market and what does it mean
for a company stock to go to zero when
you buy a stock in a company you're
essentially you're not buying a share in
all of its assets you're buying a share
and it's equity so if you look at so I
drew two banks here and we'll talk a
little bit more about what's broken but
a bank has assets and a bank has
liabilities and with you if you take the
sum of the assets and you subtract out
the liabilities what's left over is
essentially the equity and when you buy
a stock in a bank or any company you're
essentially taking a share of that so
what's broken here is through the
housing bubble a lot of these banks in
order to to facilitate this whole
securitization I can go more detail into
that what that is they essentially
accumulated these assets on their
balance sheets and this this has been
this has been thus the the central focus
of the entire bailout planning and
there's been a lot of talk about toxic
CDOs and what are they worth but I just
want to show you what they do to a
bank's balance sheet and why it's so
important that we figure out what these
things are worth because you see here
I drew the the you can kind of view the
height of this left-hand side as the
assets the height on the right hand side
of the liabilities what's left over is
the equity if this to these toxic CDOs
are worth nothing if this disappeared
then all of a sudden your assets are
worth less than your liabilities when
your house is worth less than your
mortgage then you have no equity in that
situation your stock would be worthless
and in that situation there's no reason
why anyone should be lending to you
because you're essentially throwing good
money after bad so essentially the
situation that the banks find themselves
in is the same as the one that
homeowners had found themselves in as a
result of this pretty much the
homeowners you have an asset that's
worth less than your liabilities what do
you do do you try to get someone to bill
you out and buy your asset for more than
it's worth
or do you just declare bankruptcy let's
hold off right there we're going to come
back in just a little bit we're going to
continue that conversation and we're
also going to be bringing you something
today that's an exclusive to this
particular hour on CNN the story of
curve ball who is curveball he may just
be the only person that the Bush
administration used as their source for
going to war in Iraq or certainly as
much as anyone else was he right know
who is he no one's known up to now an
exclusive interview with curveball stay
with us we'll be right back
three.com slash Rick Sanchez CNN so many
of you 23,000 I believe when we last
checked are talking to us watching this
newscast as well as on MySpace and
Facebook in fact there's somebody on
MySpace right now she's watching our
show and she just wanted us to notice he
says my son is 17 years old and excited
about college I'm worried that we won't
be able to get a loan to send him out my
husband's hours have been cut back from
work as well this absolutely affects all
of America and that's why we're doing
what we're trying to do for you let's go
back now and bring in Sal if we can Sal
Khan he explained to us moments ago what
what it is that is actually the problem
what it is that is broken now let's take
the next step let's try and understand
because everyone seems to be wondering I
don't understand this bailout / rescue
plan that the government has been in
what is what is the government actually
doing explain that to us
so we could understand it like a fifth
grader right so the the main problem
just to take the big picture was that no
one's lending to each other so what the
government at least said that they
wanted to do is try to get the lending
started again so their bailout plan was
essentially let's buy out these toxic
CDOs because if I'm let's say I'm a good
bank that didn't get involved in this if
Bank a is holding these toxic CDOs I'm
not sure if Bank a should be bankrupt if
the toxic CDOs are worth nothing or
maybe they are good for the money so
there's a lot of uncertainty on what
these are worth the government at least
what they said they would do is if they
went in and essentially did these
reverse auctions and bought these assets
then that all of a sudden would give
confidence in these banks people
wouldn't there wouldn't be uncertainty
as to whether you can loan them money
and maybe that'll free up the credit the
whole system again will it work probably
not if you think about what's going to
happen psychologically so Bank a if you
were to let's say that you know if you
were to just switch this toxic CDOs and
if you were to just turn that back into
cash because the government just bought
it
for exactly what Bank a says it's worth
so if you just turn this into cash the
question is is Bank a all of a sudden
going to start lending and there's a
couple of things to think about because
besides that toxic CDO there were other
things on its balance sheet and frankly
a lot of these things are starting to
starting to get a little bit toxic
really talking about them right now
because you know if you have a dead
skunk in your house you're not going to
notice that the milks gone bad so so
essentially you have a lot of assets on
your balance sheet right here that if
you're a prudent bank manager you're
going to see you're going to say boy I
should just keep that cash because if
these turn toxic because the economy
might be turning south or for whatever
reason I should just hold on to that
cash so that I don't go bankrupt so
everyone is in complete survival mode
even the good banks if somehow you were
to give them capital and the Paulson's
new version of the plan is that
essentially they'll inject equity so buy
stocks if you buy stock you will
essentially make the pie bigger and put
some cash here
but even this guy the good bank it's not
so clear to me that he'll actually start
lending everyone is in survival mode
this isn't a time to make new loans and
take on users so it seems like the
government went in and they have decided
you know what we're going to do we're
going to go in there and help these guys
out as soon as we help them out
everybody will realize that now they
have the government's backing so other
people will be interested in helping
them more people will give them their
money that hasn't worked that the people
and other investors haven't bought into
that when we come back I want to hear
your idea of what perhaps the government
should have done or could still do to
rescue this it's unique it's different
and the you and I have talked about it
earlier but I want you to be able to
share it with our viewers also curveball
the story that we've been telling you
about this is going to be a CNN
exclusive to this hour about one
particular individual who no one has
ever talked to before he only speaks
German and Arab you'll hear his
conversation here in the next ten
minutes stay with us we'll be right back
all right so we understand now what
actually is broken we've got a sense of
what the government tried to do to fix
it but it doesn't seem to be working
because enough people slash investors
and regular folk don't seem to be buying
into it let's bring in Shao Kahn once
again from the Khan Academy and talk
about what may be done either a would
have been the original plan that would
have worked a lot better or something we
could still do now and that is so the
big picture just going back to the big
picture is that the financial system no
one's lending through right right and
every bailout plan so far the government
is just keep it just keeps injecting
money and either through loans either
through buying assets for maybe more
than they're worth or now buying stock
and and and the logic here is is maybe
that'll start up the lending but most
probably any new money that you put into
the system to large degree is because
just going to go into survival mode or
it's going to go to essentially make up
mistakes that have already been made mmm
so one idea and this actually came from
a friend of mine todd watski and
actually think it sounded crazy when he
first said it but it actually sounds
like a really good idea is take that
seven hundred billion and remember the
problem isn't you you're not trying to
save the financial system you're trying
to save the pipe that goes from the
capital to the project so why not take
the seven hundred billion and capitalize
a brand-new financial system I mean and
and one thing one thing that Todd had
pointed out seven hundred billion it's
an astronomical amount of money that's
more than the book value of the equity
book equity is this piece right here on
the balance sheet then JP Morgan Morgan
Stanley Goldman Sachs Washington Mutual
Wachovia and Bank of America combined so
the government could overnight create
banks bigger than those banks although I
don't think they should concentrate it
all in five or six banks they should so
in other words you're saying why try and
put money into something that is so
absolutely messed up if they're half
dead let them die create a new system
altogether but wouldn't that be a
problem too because then written those
banks be owned by the government do we
want that no and and this is this is the
solution and and first of all just to
make a point clear the Paulson's current
solution involves government ownership
this plan what you could do is the
government could capitalize the banks
maybe twenty or thirty banks
around the country with the 700 million
dollars and then each of those banks
could have 300 million shares and they
could give one share to every American
new banks new totally new banks
interesting Sal Khan thanks so much
we'll keep you on we're going to be
talking about this throughout the hour
obviously we're trying to get people to
get and explain some of these things for
us and what's the market doing right now
let's put that let's make that as big as
we possibly can down 71 a lot better
than we were looking at an hour ago
maybe you had a cell in some faith
hopefully all right we're going to come
back to that and not just a little bit
but obviously one of the key stories
that we've been saving for you today
the story of curve ball the man who
seemed to have been the source of the
influence in the invasion of Iraq as we
expected Sal Khan is a bit of a hit does
things kind of differently doesn't he
and a lot of people have a lot of
comments a lot of questions for but
including this one let's go ahead and
take a Twitter Brook we possibly can
this one comes in from San Fran yeah he
watches this show a lot like every day
he says keep Kahn talking if the market
is going up apparently it had been I
hadn't even noticed that I was so
engaged in the conversation let's do
this real quick I want to just step away
from this for a moment let's your thanks
so much Sal Khan standing by she'll tell
us if you could I guess bring us back to
basics how are we being affected by what
we're seeing in the news every day the
credit crunch in the situation with the
market sure if we don't unclog the
credit system we know that every was
going to unlevered their debt so we're
gonna have D leverage mmm that's
essentially everyone unwinding their
loans D leverage and this is I think a
critical point because I think there's
been a lot of misinformation out there
that actually contracts the money supply
so a lot of people out there are worried
about inflation these deficits that lead
to inflation but when you have D
leverage and this is what happened in
Japan this is what happened in the 30s
the money supply contracts that's our
printing press leverages our printing
press international reserve system and
that's going to lead to deflation so I
think a lot of people are worried about
how we're going to see inflation are we
going to see deflation and if we don't
fix the problem we're going to see what
Japan saw and we're going to see
deflation and so the place of deflation
means what concretely to me and you
things things get cheaper the opposite
of inflation so a unfortunately B salary
we'll go down but on the plus side a lot
of assets you know people buying a house
they'll get cheaper even I know that
that probably won't be a good thing in
the short term yeah exactly not with
what situation is right now
thanks so much Don you've been a great
guest what an original way of being able
to explain things we're going to be
right back with the closing bell which
looks to be somewhere in the middle of